all the great leaders political or
Business Leaders
think act and communicate the complete
opposite of the rest of this where so
many of us start by telling people what
we do they start with why
but let me give you a funny example
that makes the case perfectly
dating
is like any kind of sales call
we're sitting across a table from
somebody
we want to say things that make them
choose us over somebody else
and imagine if we sent somebody out
on a date and they started with what
rather than why
so let's take our theoretical data let's
call him
Davido
Davido is on a date with a young woman
that his friends set him up with
and this is how the date begins he sits
across from her and the first words he
says
you know I am very very rich
I know lots of famous people
I'm on television all the time which is
good because I'm good looking
and I have a beautiful home you should
you should come and see it sometime
so the question is
does Davido get a second date
it's intuitive
no
but depends how rich he is
but
but now
but now let's send him out a second time
but this time he will start with why
ah before I do that
before I do that I should say what he
did is exactly what most companies do
they sit across the table and they say
you know we're very successful we're the
biggest in the industry
uh we have some of the wealthiest people
who work with us you may have seen our
advertising on television we have a
beautiful corporate headquarters you
should come visit sometime it's the same
thing
and so we know it doesn't work on a date
so why should it work in a sales call
and the answer is it doesn't
so let's send them out again this time
he starts with why
you know he says
I love what I do
I work for an organization that has a
belief
that we are responsible
for holding the dreams of other people
in our hands
it gives me purpose it's why I wake up
in the morning every single day
and the result is fantastic
I've actually been able to make a lot of
money and meet a lot of famous people
and I get to be on television all the
time which is fun because I'm good
looking and I built a beautiful house
but the most important thing is the
reason why I get out of bed in the
morning
and you can see all the same facts are
in there but this time starting with why
gives context to all those things so all
the facts still prove they serve as the
tangible proof but it's a profoundly
different feeling when somebody leaves
with purpose